[Musica]
siamo distanziate quindi possiamo
parlare speriamo serenamente di quello
che è un ruolo che non tanti conoscono e
che però valorizza anche in questo caso
la figura la donna in un ambito non
scontato lei è stata la donna giudice
più giovane d'italia erano gli anni 90
spe non erro a modena sono due le donne
su dieci magistrati
cosi ci
rende bene l'idea è quindi partirà
le chiedo quanto è stato difficile ma
ancora quanto
intraprendere questa carriera grazie e
buona sera a tutti a tutti è molto
difficoltoso perché la donna il fiscale
è sempre stata immaginata come una
persona estranea a ciò che riguarda le
imposte le tasse ed è una competenza
specifica molto di nicchia ma quando
allora nel lontano 1989 il presidente
della corte d'appello mi chiamò perché
si liberò un po sì ma vuoi fare il
giudice tributario al che rimasi un po
stupita ma anche ambito e grazie a lui
mi nominò come giudice d'appello poi nel
1896 finalmente uscire di concorsi
perché anche due giudici tributari
accediamo alla professione di magistrato
attraverso un concorso pubblico e in
effetti lei ha detto bene perché su
1.200 giudici allora solo dieci donne io
ero la più giovane con me concorso
sono anche vice presidenti anche qui
sempre un concorso per titoli e quindi
dobbiamo sempre molto studiare
sacrificare anche sabati e domeniche
perché le sentenze devono essere sempre
aggiornate non solo con le leggi ma
anche la nostra giurisprudenza della
corte di cassazione e dobbiamo sempre
dare al cittadino
contribuente il diritto alla difesa
il direttore legalità perché devono
sapere che noi come quarta giurisdizione
dobbiamo rispettare il nostro ruolo di
imparzialità quindi si sa che dall'altra
parte ci sia l'agenzia delle entrate che
dall'altra parte ci possa essere gli
enti locali oi difensori avvocati
contribuenti e questo è veramente un
sacrificio perché vuol dire sempre
studiare quindi anche la tua vita
privata a volte è un po un sacrificio
come donna era proprio questa la domanda
che lei volevo fare abbiamo visto prima
negli speach di altre due protagoniste
insieme quanto siano bassi anche i
numeri delle zone con sti importanti
libre steve carr e molto nella scuola
fare molti sacrifici perché svolgendo
anche altre attività anche dover stare
eccetera poi come ricercatrice a bologna
giusta di bologna però ho sempre avuto
una grossa fortuna nella vita di amare
il lavoro di amare tutto ciò che è nuovo
tutto ciò che mi può stimolare cioè
l'appiattimento non fa per me io devo
sempre cercare di capire cosa studio
cosa faccio cosa posso dare agli altri
ma in particolare ai giovani
perché i giovani sono il nostro futuro e
far capire anche nei nostri progetti che
facciamo dodicenne le scuole anche per
le pari opportunità deve essere uno
stimolo per i giovani per dire abbiate
fiducia nella giustizia
abbiate fiducia anche nelle noi donne
che non siamo sempre ghettizzate ecc e
chiaro che ci sono state i sacrifici
perché
prima è una materia continuamente in
evoluzione
col kobe di ancora più peggiorata ma
ovviamente dobbiamo sempre anche
guardare circolare dell'agenzia delle
entrate guardare un attimo tutto anche
gli accertamenti della guarda di finanza
però
accanto a me ho sempre avuto la fortuna
di avere un grande uomo grande marito
che mi ha sempre stimolato ad andare
avanti ad essere sempre molto rigorosa
con me stessa a non perdere mai di vista
l'obiettivo che cos'è che sono un
giudice e devo garantire a tutti ai
giovani di credere perché se non
crediamo nei nostri diritti nella nostra
giustizia viene meno anche aver fiducia
in se stesse quindi è questo che cerco
di trasmettere anche i miei giovani
studenti che sono anche collegati e
quindi ringrazio moltissimo di questa
occasione di portare la mia materia
fisco legalità a un pubblico
generale eterogeneo sta portando una
bellissima testimonianza anche perché
come ha detto lei quello che deve
esserci lo ha detto anche chiaramente
chiarati lesina perdura è un cambiamento
anche culturale che deve partire dalle
donne ma anche dagli uomini le giorni
anche per prendere maggiore conoscenza e
coscienza di noi stesse dall'uomo perché
comunque appunto con uomini come magari
suo marito si riesce poi anche ad avere
il coraggio di magari fare ancora più
sacrifici per portare avanti quella che
è la professione e da qui allora l'altra
domanda che giornalisticamente mi ha
subito solleticato la curiosità è perché
quando parliamo anche di reati di
evasione fiscale
forse perché i soldi girano più attorno
agli uomini ci sono più uomini che
vengono arrestati in questi anni ma
diciamo che noi guardiamo anche gli
aspetti penali
nel senso che sulle nostre sui nostri
tavoli ovviamente c'è molta evasione e
quello che cerco di dire ai giovani è
questo
cercate sempre di guardare al futuro di
pensare che se c'è una giustizia non
bisogna fare l'evasione perché vuol dire
che toglie ai giovani lavoro sanità
istruzione le infrastrutture e la
sicurezza perché i soldi che ovviamente
incassiamo lo stato lo dà per i servizi
pubblici e questo è fondamentale per noi
cercare di coinvolgere i giovani perché
è vero che sono più che altro le società
e gli uomini come dice lei però ad
esempio ci sono capitati dei casi
regionali in commissione tenuta
regionale che ancora il racconto ai
ragazzi anche donne famose soubrette
anche milano ad esempio hai bevuto dei
casi eclatanti eccetera
ma il caso esempio due professioniste
che avevano avuto degli accertamenti da
parte l'agenzia delle entrate che c'è
anche il direttore che ringrazio di
essere con noi utenti alle entrate dove
una era stato colpito da un tumore
quindi doveva fare delle cure
particolari quindi per sei mesi non
aveva lavorato un altro professionista
commercialista che invece aveva avuto la
maternità e quindi non ero riuscita a
rientrare nei parametri studi settore e
io stata fortunata perché sono riuscita
a far capire nel mio collegio giudicante
che comunque ci sono dei diritti delle
leggi che tutelano la donna anche
maternità o anche malattie oncologiche
per cui non poteva essere legittimo
quell'accertamento perché anche se aveva
dichiarato di meno non c'era evasione
non c'era nero e questo devo dire che
poche sono le donne a volte le imprese
ecco l'impegno sui familiari vivono più
volte anche la collaboratrice le donne
però
sono più gli uomini è così devo dire la
verità ha parlato dei giovani c'è un
progetto molto interessante che si
chiama processo simulato per formarli
educarli di cosa si tratta sì perché nel
lontano 12 anni fa noi siamo anche i
giudici europei per cui grazie anche
l'università dove noi abbiamo fatto dei
must crociate formazione abbiamo pensato
bene di coinvolgere non solo gli
studenti universitari ma anche le scuole
dal liceo classico e 100 sentivi studi
tecnici e cosa facciamo andiamo nelle
scuole insieme ai difensori dei
contribuenti all'agenzia rientrata
guardi finanze nei giudici andiamo
spiegare come si fa una di caso dei
redditi quindi facciamo compilare ai
ragazzi la dichiarazione dei redditi
cos'è l'imposta cos'è la tassa ma la
cosa bella di questo percorso annuale
anno scolastico e il processo simulato
cioè che cosa gli stessi studenti
fanno la parte del dell'avvocato il
commercialista la parte del
dell'agenzia delle entrate e collegi
giudicanti che ovviamente il presidente
siamo noi giudici veri insomma è un
giudice vero e tra di loro che è una
cerimonia finale eccetera
facciamo trattiamo dei casi ovviamente
semplici non complicate sempre le
sponsorizzazioni ed associazioni
sportive dilettantistiche eccetera e
insieme tra di loro è bello perché con
la toga si vedono protagonisti in quel
momento di capire che cos'è cosa vuol
dire cercare di difendere contrattaccare
l'agenzia delle entrate che viene sempre
vista come l'oppressore colui che è
sempre a certa tutti ma non è così e
quindi i giovani si appassionano e
questo mi rende orgogliosa perché a
livello nazionale il nostro progetto non
solo nazionale ma confrontandoci anche
con gli altri giudici tedeschi spagnoli
eccetera
è un progetto che sto cercando di
esportare anche all'estero si
appassionano di più i ragazzi le ragazze
in egual misura ma in quale misura devo
dire che ragazzi e ragazze anche se le
ragazze sotto un po perplessi perché è
molto tecnica la materia abbiamo anche
delle studentesse straniere per cui
cerchiamo di trattare anche degli
argomenti
che coinvolgono anche gli stranieri ma
devo dire che è uguale perché i giovani
è quello che io dico di nuovo cos'è e
dare loro fiducia
il cobit anche le nostre udienze da
remoto ci hanno un po soffocato perché
anche a dietro la difesa vedersi
attraverso una tv è sempre un po
limitativa ma
attraverso i giovani dico sempre cercate
di avere fiducia in voi stessi di
credere in ciò che io vi trasmetto la
passione la passione oltre che per le
pari opportunità ovviamente
discriminazione ma la passione che ho da
30 anni come giudice tributario questo è
il sorriso un po come dicevamo anche di
speaker che mi è piaciuto molto sono
contenta che molti giovani ci seguono e
la fiducia crede in se stesso e parlare
perché questo manca e il coach ha un po
costretto limitato parlare e saper
ascoltare
per chiudere non posso non chiederle
senza magari fare nome e cognome però un
aneddoto curioso che è legato alla sua
professione ma ce ne sono stati tanti
ad esempio il famoso
rossi valentino ecco l'abbiamo trattato
tomba insomma mi ha avuto tantissimi
casi ma sono stati carini perché avendo
la residenza fiscale all'estero è l'ora
andare insegnare anche agli studenti
che cosa devono fare anche se uno ai
paradisi fiscali
deve comunque sapere che gli
accertamenti e le tecniche investigative
dell'asinara bar di finanza sono molto
capillare per cui noi come giudici
cerchiamo di
controllare verificare
ciò che è importante però la
soddisfazione sono anche dei genitori in
questo processo tributario perché molti
genitori
mi avvicino anno a vicino a noi
associazione magistrati tributari che
sono anche la presidente regionale anche
nazionale della formazione e vengono
vicini ringraziano perché vedono che
diamo la passione l'entusiasmo e questo
dovremmo sempre ricordarselo un sorriso
ascoltare parlare e dare fiducia che
anche chi è limitato comunque può
riuscire nella vita a fare anche giudice
tributario che non è cosa sempre grazie
a mirella guicciardi per il suo
intervento
[Musica]